[MUSIC PLAYING]
LARRY P. ARNN: This
graduate school
was inspired by
George Washington
to teach the things, the large
things, that a statesman would
need to know to govern
this country well.
MATTHEW SPALDING: What's missing
in a lot of politics today
is, we have a lot
of people that want
to talk about first principles.
And, of course, we have
a lot of people that
want to focus just on action.
It's connecting the two that's
the virtue of statesmanship.
TOM COTTON: Education
is about more than just
turning out good workers.
It should be about turning
out good citizens, as well,
the next generation
of Americans who
understand the timeless
principles of our government.
And, unfortunately, too
many schools, and especially
universities, not only
fail in that mission,
but they actively
repudiate that mission.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY: Young
people who come to this town
don't have that
founding understanding
of how government should be
and how it will best operate.
JAMIE DANGERS: So I'm excited
about learning the larger story
and how to
incorporate the wisdom
of people who came before us
into a very fraught culture
right now.
MATTHEW SPALDING:
We're going to look
at core documents,
original documents,
we're going to
study the writings
and thoughts of great
statesmen and great books.
LARRY P. ARNN:
And it will mostly
be taken by people who
work in the government.
And they will read old books.
They'll start with Plato
and Aristotle and Herodotus
and Thucydides.
And they'll learn
what politics is,
and then they'll
learn what America is.
Understand how the
Constitution works,
and then it'll teach
the alternatives
to the Constitution that have
grown up in understanding
and in institutions
in America, that
are the abnegation
of the Constitution.
And then you'll be equipped
to go out in the world
and make some decisions.
To be a fine human being, you
need to have good character.
To be a fine human being and
the finest kind of human being,
you need to understand the
ultimate purposes of life
and everything else.
And, finally, to be a fine human
being, you need to be free.
We're a college aiming
for all those four things.
And so the way we're
serious about that
is to teach in ways that
are helpful to being
better and governing a
free country, the United
States of America.
We can help ambitious
people to understand
what that is so they can
cultivate it within themselves
and learn from it, and
that is of huge value.
[RAPID DRUM BEATS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]